welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
boss and perhaps the biggest mystery for
obi-wan kenobi on disney plus is the way
this new chapter of star wars history
affects one iconic line from the very
first time we saw these two characters
together back in 1977 star wars on the
death star when i left you i was but the
learner now i am the master a quote that
apparently now will have an entirely new
context and meaning with the rematch of
this series actually series director
deborah chow confirmed that this quote
from the 77 film was something they kept
in mind while shooting these episodes
and even ewan mcgregor said that they
worked backwards and forwards at the
same time to make sure all this made
sense so this is episode 2 of our
between the duels series and we are
going to be working backward and forward
on how the context of this obi-wan
kenobi series is a story we can decipher
from the star wars films series novels
comics and in this episode we're gonna
break down that famous darth vader quote
to piece together what star wars will
now reveal him to be referring to in
that moment on the death star and to
best recontextualize his statement we
really should break it down into three
parts first when i left you when obi-wan
and anakin battle on mustafar in revenge
of the sith what we previously thought
to be their last encounter it was
obi-wan who walked away from him but now
vader's saying when i left you suggest
that this time around it will be vader
who walks away from his former master
obviously both men survive this duel and
obi-wan won't be too banged up because
he doesn't look too bad when we pick
back up with him in a new hope or really
slightly before that in rebels season 3
episode 20 twin suns the epic rematch
between obi-wan and maul that said many
are wondering why ewan mcgregor in this
series looks more like the virile sexy
scotsman that we left in revenge of the
sith than the hardened desert wizard in
twin suns and in a new hope was it just
nine more years of living in the climate
of sand with its tendency to be coarse
and rough and irritating and get
everywhere or could we be looking at a
before and after sith lightning
palpatine style touch up with his
rematch with vader being so stressful
that the old man is left with a thousand
new gray hairs i don't know but either
way evade or win give us some nice
poetry as one could argue obi-wan had
the high ground in both of the other two
fights between them obviously he beat
anakin on mustafar but then was able to
become one with the force on the death
star it just now leads us to wonder how
could this fight in the obi-wan kenobi
series be so brutal and yet still end in
a way that vader allows obi-wan to
survive it and simply walk away from him
but perhaps the most mysterious part of
darth vader's death star quote was
really the second clause of it i was but
a learner that tells us that as vader
faces obi-wan on this series actually
when he looks back on this fight nine
years from now he will consider himself
still in the learning process a student
still coming of age a guy still on his
first couple babel classes in erkatot
which is actually worse news for obi-wan
than you think i mean think about it no
one is more obnoxious than that young
buck who just had their mind blown at a
new school or a new coach a new pastor a
new improv class and then suddenly
thinks they know everything uh-huh yeah
everyone else here has also read that
freakonomics chapter you just spent 40
minutes recapping can we just enjoy
these b-dub swings please that
superficial academic arrogance is going
to be a nightmare for obi-wan to have to
deal with because it means vader will
still be especially resentful of the
previous paradigm that he had to leave
and especially desperate to confirm to
himself the dark side is the right path
for him and he will still be
unquestioningly loyal to sidious's
teachings drunk on the kool-aid add this
to the confidence of vader already
knowing he's the chosen one thanks to
the closest thing star wars has to gods
telling him that in the clone wars
season 3 mortis storyline when anakin
obi-wan and ahsoka met the forced
deities of the father the daughter and
the son all them feuding over anakin's
cosmic significance now revenge of the
sith showed the start of sidious
tutelage of anakin from his lecture
series on darth plagueis the wise to his
whole overview of the course anakin
if one is to understand the great
mystery one must study all its aspects
not just the dogmatic narrow view of the
jedi
if you wish to become a complete and
wise leader you must embrace
a larger view of the force and we saw
and against fall from this film to his
suiting up in his classic vader armor
but we actually only got a glimpse of
just how painful wearing that suit would
be for obi-wan kenobi shows his chest
piece sticking into his abdomen with
prods that dig into his flesh also the
interior of his helmet is lined with
needles that fuse with his brain making
the whole suit not just an extension of
his remaining flesh but leaving him in
constant pain all to fuel his rage now
the time after revenge of the sith is
explored and chuck's soul's amazing
darth vader comics charting his
educational path first he needs a new
lightsaber the emperor teaches vader
about red kyber crystals how the
crystals that power lightsabers actually
feel pain like we do and can be made to
bleed by pouring rage into them so to
get a new crystal vader's gotta hunt a
jedi kill that jedi and then claim their
lightsaber he locates should i master
kirak and fila against whom he struggles
but eventually kills and takes his blade
then he brings that crystal to a sith
cave on mustafar to make it bleed the
crystal initially fights back with
visions of anakin's weakness but he
rejects the visions and overcomes the
crystal after this the emperor then
assigns vader to oversee the inquisitors
at the works and his hunt for other jedi
survivors comes to include temple
librarian jocasta new you remember her
from attack of the clones she sneaks
back into the temple to acquire a list
of four sensitive children the emperor
wants vader's like there couldn't be
only one apprentice destroying the list
and killing poor jacosta he also then
lies to the emperor about it which is
interesting but the emperor later sends
vader back to mustafar so he can build
his castle there something vader wants
to do to try to open a pathway to
resurrect padme but the emperor gives
him an ancient mask that actually
contains the essence of the former sith
lord moment moment tries to overtake
vader but fails leading to this insane
vision of vader's past present and
future that we've talked about in past
videos it's an amazing moment in the
comics and ends with vader realizing he
cannot bring padme back and he seals off
his door in rage still not a master and
that now brings us to the third part of
vader's death star quote now i am the
master it is a pretty bold statement for
vader to make at that time considering
he's still on the junior side of the
sith rula 2 relationship with sidious so
for him to say that i think that
connects to his willingness to lie to
his master back in the comics and
indicates that for his rematch with
obi-wan will fuel his ego his ambition
and his buried hostility toward his
master when these two lock sabers
obi-wan will likely leave a seed of
insubordination in the mind of his
former student i thought this was
supposed to be your new empire or is it
the emperors and that way when they are
both older men on the death star and
when vader says play it again when i
left you i was but the learner now i am
the master and obi wan coolly shoots
back only a monster will be built
in addition to messing with vader's head
by calling him darth like it's his first
name kenobi already knows that he has
got his former student beat he will end
this final duel becoming one with the
force leaving behind an egomaniacal
glory hog looking for just the right
moment to turn on his master i cannot
wait to see the moment this iconic line
from the original star wars film is
given deeper context in this obi-wan
kenobi series i want to thank you for
joining us for chapter 2 of between the
duels in future chapters we'll look at
what jedi might still be alive at this
point in history and who exactly these
inquisitors are who are hunting them be
sure to subscribe to new rockstars
follow me on instagram and twitter at
eaboss and follow new rockstars thanks
for watching bye
[Music]
you